الطريق من الخرطوم الى معبر اشكيت على
الحدود المصريه يبعد اكثر من الف كيلو متر
قطعها هؤلاء على مدى ايام فالمعارك لم
تترك لهم فرصه للبقاء في العاصمه ورحله
البحث عن النجاه لم تكن يسيره محمد اول
طالب من نيجيريا استطاع ان يفره مع عائلته
ونحن طلعنا من الخرطوم
من الاسبوع الفاتحه يعني
من بيوتنا من وطننا من اولادنا من اهلنا
من قبيلتنا
ملايين ملايين زينا ما براينا وانا حاسه
مريضه ما بقدر اجيب على رجولي عندي
عمليتين في رجولي ولسه ماشي على عمليه ما
اقدر اقيفه على طول
يشعر الحاج محمد بالمراره ازاء من يصفهم
بتجار الازمات الذين يستغلون اوضاع الناس
الصعبه البلد دي خربوها عدد كبير من
السماسره الداخلين يعني تلقى العربيه
واقفه في الخرطوم يركبوك بسعر بعد شويه لا
اطلع العربيه التانيه بسعر لبعد شويه
بعربيه ثالثه للسعر يعني زي كده صباحا اذا
قمت اثنين صباحا ثاني يوم يكون اجمل لانه
الجماعه داخلين كلهم في المواضيع دي يعني
في ناس كذبوا ملايين الملايين ودين الناس
الخاينين للوطن وخاينين للبلد وللمعانات
وجه اخر فبسبب ظروف الحرب سهلت الاجراءات
في معبر اشكيت
تم استثناء المسافرين بوضع ضوابط واجراءات
سفر جديده متعلقه بالذين فقدوا جوازاتهم
وبالاطفال الذين ليس لهم جوازات سفر وكل
الحالات الموضحه في المنشورات الرسميه
الصادره من اداره المعبر موضح فيها
الضوابط والتفاصيل التي من شان ان تسهل
وتيسر السفر الى جمهوريه مصر العربيه
تغيرت اذا الصوره تماما في هذا المركز
الحدودي فبعد ان كان معبر للزائرين
والتجار بات ملاذا للنازحين ممن كانوا قبل
اسابيع يعيشون حياه عاديه قبل ان تغير
الحرب يومياتهم رحله شاقه من اجل الحياه
الفارون من جحيم معارك الخرطوم تجمعهم
المعاناه وان تعدد التفاصيل قصصهم تركوا
ورائهم كل شيء من اجل اهم شيء النجاه
بحياتهم حسن الرزاق الجزيره من معبر اشكيت
على الحدود السودانيه المصريه